millions of learners today are watching
videos online
using platforms such as khan academy
coursera
edx and youtube as thousands of learners
interact with the same video content
they're watching behaviors lead to
collective interaction patterns
these patterns might indicate points of
confusion interest
and importance we introduce lecturescape
a video player that's powered by a set
of data driven video interaction
techniques
lecturescape enhances the video timeline
to help learners identify and navigate
to important parts of the video
unlike a traditional linear timeline the
rollercoaster timeline is
2d with an embedded visualization of
second by second navigation frequency of
all learners and resulting interaction
peaks
it also modifies the timeline dragging
behavior
by creating a sensor friction while
dragging
the playhead around peaks as a result
frames near the peaks are exposed longer
and
are easier to precisely navigate to in
addition to
collective watching traces letterscape
also keeps track of personal watching
phrases and visualizes in real time
the segments of the video that the
current learner has watched
clicking on the generated segment
replays that segment
lecturescape uses interaction data to
better support
searching for relevant information
inside a video
when the learner types in a search query
the search timeline appears below the
video
it visualizes the positions of search
results
as well as the relative importance of
each
our search algorithm rewards results in
sections of the video
where more learners watched lecturescape
uses interaction data to create a visual
summarization of video clip
lecturescape presents a strip of visual
highlights below the video
to enable a quick overview of important
points
these are the frames frequently watched
by other learners
clicking on a frame plays that point in
the video
the learner can also bookmark their own
frame of interest and add notes
which is then added to the highlights
stream below the video
in educational videos instructors often
refer
to concepts and formulas introduced
earlier in the video
but the referred slides are no longer
available on screen
lecturescape automatically pins a
relevant frame next to the video for
quick reference